[Music]
yeah
um I just wanted to thank you for all
your help yesterday I didn't do much it
was nothing good day
very busy
get back to work what are you having
there
a balloon arch oh my God Captain she is
magnificent
Vindication
there's a confused old woman here who
wants to talk to a detective
oh come on another drill hello my name
is Adelaide I'd like to report a crime
so we're just doing one of these every
day oh you got it I know you got it I
want my money
why are we doing this it's Captain's
orders my name is Adelaide van Hoyt I'm
89 years old
and I'm here to report a crime not a
problem we can help you
Adelaide van Hoyt 89 years old
goatee 6'3 290 Pounds hey this is a
tight 240. show Adelaide some damn
respect
captain
we are done with the drill the old lady
confessed to a 40 year old unsolved
murder in Rhode Island we filled out the
interstate file request and remanded her
to the custody of her daughter Adelaide
has successfully transformed back into a
giant man sir
well done thank you
see instead of resisting it's better to
just put your head down get the job done
and then you can get on with your day hi
my name is Timmy and I'm lost
[ __ ] so do you recognize any of these
men I was hiding in the bathroom stall
so I didn't see his face but I heard him
he was singing along to the music at the
bar do you remember what he was singing
I think it was that song I Want It That
Way Backstreet Boys I'm familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to I Want It That Way really
okay
you are
My Fire
number two keep it going the one
desire number three believe when I say
number four I wanted that away tell me
why ain't nothing but a heartache tell
me why you ain't nothing but a mistake
now number five I never wanna hear you
say
[Applause]
oh chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
God I forgot about it yes lunch time
waits over that was easy totally I feel
like we just had our snack an hour and
17 minutes ago I never got into diet
though I did take diet pills in the 70s
I love these pills they give me so much
energy and I can eat whatever I want
oh God
he's dead actually I was in a coma when
I woke up I had so much mail
weight loss signs has come a long way
since then
ingredients carrot gotta respect that uh
damn Gina what is that oh it's the
sloppy Jessica mac and cheese chili
pizza on a bun it's everything I've
wanted to eat for the last 48 hours
what happened I thought you were gonna
last forever [ __ ] turns out I gave up
Uzu you hear that [ __ ] I gave up so
easy
we're working on that afternoon almond
I've been sucking on it so long it's
smooth it's like sea glass you do you
um
I'll get that boy games
oops butter feed sorry about that sorry
you bumbling son of a [ __ ] you just
ruined my life I hope you get hit by a
truck and a dog takes a dump on your
face ain't nothing to see here just a
little hypoglycemic rage move along I'm
so sorry Hitchcock that's not me I'm
never like that that's okay it's my
fault I shouldn't bumped your cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot I hope
you've drown in a tub I hope you have an
aneurysm after aneurysm after aneurysm
attention I've been asked to read this
statement two months ago Gina linetti
was hit by a bus and the brightest star
in the cosmos was extinguished but today
like a phoenix From the Ashes she Rises
to Vanquish
this is 10 pages I can't read it
Judith's doctor said it was okay for her
to come back to work today here she is
as I've been in and I can't imagine what
it's been like for you living in a
genius world for two months I'll field
some questions now anyone how long do
you have to wear the the metal the head
holder called a Halo the doctor said I
have to wear it for another week it's
drilled into my skull here and yes I can
still hear the screws squeaking into the
bone so what was it like getting hit by
a bus it was awesome I knew it I always
wanted to get hit by a bus yeah I mean I
was legally dead for two full minutes
and I met God tight what does she look
like ethnically ambiguous you took two
weeks off when Courtney and Scott Disick
broke up are you sure you're ready to be
back at work now what are you saying
Terry you think I can't handle being
back yet
watch this
[Music]
I want to apologize for yesterday
inserting myself into my employees
breakup with my nephew somehow
uh backfired snagfall I'm on the
medicine like a dumb crying baby
I'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the end of the
world to feel
things I guess not
it's up there
thing is I really cared about Marcus but
he wanted to get married and
I'm just not ready for that and if I'm
not ready with a guy as great as Marcus
then
what if I'm never ready what if that was
it my one chance of love
and what if I never get a second chance
I don't know
I'm just
sad
I understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this
for you
and you and you what are these these
madam are STDs
what are you talking about Buddy STDs
save the dates for Viviana my wedding ah
yes hey just out of curiosity how many
people have you given STDs to Lots like
a hundred
what's going on uh oh okay I get it STD
has another meaning you're gross no one
else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you it
is kind of sweet will your first dance
be to you give me fever will you be
serving crabs at the reception do you
have herpes guys
and we're sorry yes we love you buddy
warts and all sorry I made a rash
decision I was itching to say it okay
I'm done
I have an STD
so just RSVP or yeah the numbers right
on there